- Pas de rouge, pas de blanc
sur la colline du Parlement,
cette année, mais partout
du orange à la mémoire des
enfants autochtones disparus.
(chants)
Ils étaient des milliers
à marcher en appui aux peuples
autochtones, guidés par
une survivante des écoles
résidentielles.
Une solidarité qui transcende
les cultures et les
générations : Autochtones,
non-Autochtones, jeunes,
moins jeunes; tous réunis
pour lancer un message.
CLAUDETTE COMMANDA, Conféd. des
centres éduc. cult. Pre. Nations
- C'est très important pour
les Canadiens qui sont ici
avec nous autres aujourd'hui
pour voir, pour les voir,
leur "voices", pour dire :
"Canada, wake up!"
(tambours)
- Le son des tambours a résonné
partout au pays.
(chants)
L'heure est au recueillement.
Comprendre la peine et
la douleur de tous ces parents
qui n'ont jamais revu
leurs enfants.
Un moment de réflexion,
l'occasion de faire
un appel à l'action.
Le premier ministre
Justin Trudeau reconnaît
l'ampleur du drame. Il a
lui-même demandé que le drapeau
du Canada reste en berne.
JUSTIN TRUDEAU,
premier ministre du Canada
- La plus grosse erreur
qu'on a faite en tant que pays,
ça a été l'assimilation forcée
des enfants autochtones
par les pensionnats qui a causé
des effets néfastes
qui durent aujourd'hui.
- (tous): No cry to genocide!
- Pour les leaders autochtones,
il faut affronter le passé,
comprendre les chapitres
les plus sombres
de l'histoire, tout en
restant unis pour guérir.
Une prise de conscience,
un moment d'introspection.
- L'histoire canadienne
à l'école, on n'apprend pas
vraiment cette partie-ci
et c'est vraiment important.
Et si on na pas le savoir,
on ne peut pas bouger
et changer les choses.
- Plusieurs Canadiens commencent
à comprendre qu'il y a des
injustices. Quand il y a des
plaies, il faut les guérir parce
que ça devient de plus en plus
maligne et c'est comme un
cancer.
- Un pas de plus dans le long
chemin vers la réconciliation,
alors que les adultes de demain
veulent déjà changer les choses
pour qu'on se souvienne
de chaque enfant.
Ici Estelle Côté-Sroka,
Radio-Canada, O